hello everyone and welcome to the actual
last game we'll be showing from the
feeder candidates tournament i didn't uh
i think i was going to show it but so
many of you requested it and it is a
fine game so i thought all right let's
show it and we're going to discuss the
standings a little bit but only a little
bit because we've discussed the length
in the previous video and also something
you guys requested is uh to show what
happens uh to the uh actual uh
ranking uh because the the some players
lost the rating points some players gain
rating points who entered the top 10 who
dropped out of the top 10 uh and so on
but we're going to discuss this after
the game now you guys will enjoy it it's
fabiano carwana versus saliresafiroja uh
both of them not having the tournament
of their lives so okay for alireza it's
the first candidate that he's uh playing
um most likely not the last but uh fabi
everyone expected him to either win it
or you know to almost win it but here
he's having a disastrous second half of
the tournament first half of the
tournament he was just crushing everyone
okay he didn't win all the games but he
didn't lose any of the games and he won
some of the games but here uh in the
second half of the tournament as it's a
double round robin uh zero wins for fabi
and uh well many losses and many draws
so far he has three draws and three
losses and now he has a
chance to finish the tournament on a
high note
he does have the
white pieces in the final round so let's
see what happened here bobby has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 sorry
about that
uh we have e5 by alireza uh knights to
f3 knight to c6 and now bishop to b5 the
rue lopez is on the board knight to f6
we have the berlin defense as everyone
is playing that obviously d3 bishop the
c5 and now b captures on c6 or rather
bishop captures on the c6 d captures on
c6 knight b to d2 uh we've seen this
many many times tonight is coming to c4
to go after the e5 pawn so of course
knight to d7 and f6 will be played we've
seen this many times as well knight d7
castles and uh alireza castles too we
have knight to c4 now
attacking the e5 pawn f6 by alireza and
the king the h1 and here there are some
games where a5 was played but alireza
plays rook to f7 and it is now already
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game uh so uh fabi goes knight to h4
he wants to put the knight on f5 also
this opens up the uh uh possibility of
pushing f4 uh bishop to f8 uh and now
knight to f5 we have knights to c5 now
opening up an attack towards the knight
and the queen to h5 nicely defending
this knight with bishop to e6 putting
pressure on this knight hoping for the
capture and then maybe d captures on c4
but now fabi just plays b3 and now of
course if you capture we're gonna
capture with the b pawn and everything
is perfectly fine uh queen the d7 uh
developing the queen eliza now prepares
to bring the rook into the game bishop
to e3 and now king the h8
uh
we have knights to h4 now uh trying to
take advantage of this weird uh square
that the king is occupying to go knights
the g6 check maybe as the h1 is pinned
but just king back to g8 we have queen
back to e2 by fabi and now rook to e8 so
fabi has to figure out a different way
of how to uh reach alireza's king
we have a4 and now ponte b6 we have rook
to g1 and here by playing rook to g1
fabi is saying that he is not of a
peaceful mind he wants to play g4 open
up the position put the knight back on
f5 and start some sort of an attack
against talireza's king we have pawn to
a5 well this is all right you do that
i'm gonna wait uh knights the d2 ended
now pawn to f5 by alireza now uh keeping
around that g4 square but uh fabi just
captures we have e captures on f5 bishop
captures knight captures we have queen
captures on f5 and now even bishop
captures on c5
eliminating this knight bishop captures
on c5 and now we have knight to e4
attacking the bishop here and the
defending that f2 pawn as it was um
under attack so bishop to b4 and now we
have rook gita
f1 so
for the moment not touching that g pawn
uh we have queen to g6 and now rook 8 to
d1 so far we put all of his pieces on
light squares as already has a dark
square bishop and basically what you
have to ask yourself uh here is uh
uh well who is better one thing that you
can notice is that alireza has a double
c pawn so obviously that's good for fabi
and another thing is alireza has a
bishop for a knight as the game is on
both sides of the board a bishop should
be a little bit better than knight uh
but it's not like anything is going to
happen uh or or is anything is going to
be happening on the queen side so a
knight should be a little bit better
here uh also there's no uh d-pawn or f
pawn to kick away the knight from this
beautiful e4 square so the knight should
be better than the bishop here but
alireza starts the attack he plays h5
and now fabi plays g3 g3 is is a very
interesting move because it's it's also
a target already can just attack it with
h4 another thing to consider is maybe
pawn to f3 and then if alireza ever
pushes the pawn all the way just capture
with the g captures on h3 and try and
use the open or semi-open g file to
attack the black king but okay g3 by
fabi uh and now we have rook to f8
rookie the f8 just doubling up on the f
file uh d4 now challenging the spawn uh
e captures on d for rook captures and
now pawn to h4 trying to open up the
position here uh and fabi just plays g
captures an h4 sort of um you know
playing like an engine because usually
you never want to do this even if it it
wins upon you don't want to open up your
king's position like this
but what else is there you could play
something like f4 and then if h captures
h captures maybe put the king in g2 try
and use the h file for your own rooks so
this is possible but the fabi decides to
go for g captures on h4 and now rook to
f4 by alireza
uh he goes after the the the h4 pawn so
queen the c4 with check uh king the h8
and now knight to g5 by fab you're
really going for the for the attack here
uh but it's hard to
uh it's hard to accomplish it with b5
while it is a very very tricky move uh
and uh here fabi has to make a choice
does he want to draw or does he want to
try and push this for a win because if
he wants a draw he can play queen to e6
attack the queen here and the
following is is basically forced queen
captures and e6 knight captures attacks
both of the rooks so you have to play
rook captures on f2 threatened to
capture on f1 captures captures and now
we trade everything a captures on b5 c
captures on b5 knight captures on c7
rook captures and c2 and knight captures
on b5 and you get this position where
fabi is up upon but it's a double h pawn
and you're not gonna be winning this
anytime soon so that's basically one
option and the other one is to try and
push this for a win and that's exactly
what fabi does here fabi plays queen to
d3 offers a queen trade but um it's a a
bit of a different structure than what
we see in here and it avoids all of the
unnecessary traits however this leaves
alireza a little bit better because the
queen captures on d3 rook captures and
now b captures on a4 b captures on a4
and bishop to d6 and now you can see
that this h2 pawn could be a problem
rook captures an h2 on h4 going for the
h2 pawn uh it's uh very hard for fabi to
look for winning chances here but okay
he plays rook to c3
and then now rook captures on a4 you
you'd expect rook captures on h4 but
it's actually not that big of a deal
because here you can play f4 uh block
the bishop and once uh the pawn is
captured let's say rook f captures uh on
f4 rook captures on f4 rook captures on
f4 now you're just gonna play uh rook
captures on c6 and
it's not a problem rook captures an a4
knight to f7 check we go after the
bishop king h7 knight captures on d6 c
captures and everything gets traded off
this will be an easy draw however rook
captures on a4 is a different story uh
because it keeps all the material and uh
now uh lereza has the past a pawns that
he can start pushing uh we have rook
characters and c6 by fabi rook captures
an h for now and pawn to f4
and the problem is uh the position is
not winning for alireza uh but it's not
uh all that clear uh what the easiest
way um uh it is uh because here all it
is i played a rook h captures on f4 the
absolute cleanest way is just bishop
captures on f4
because it doesn't matter what you do
obviously you have to defend the h2 pawn
if you play knight to f3
then we just continue with rook to h6 we
offer a rook trade and now after some
move that you can make for example
knight to e5 a very tricky move you
can't capture because the rook on f8
falls uh we're gonna trade rook captures
knight captures and now we start pushing
the pawn pawn to a4 let's say 95 again
with the same idea king h7 now comes
knight to c4 and the game continues um
uh with the the the past pawn being
pretty much not pretty much the past
point is unstoppable king to g6 you're
gonna have to play rook to a1 but now
we're gonna play rook to a8 and once we
put the bishop on this diagonal uh that
pawn is is coming forward so uh going to
be winning and another thing is instead
of knight to f3 you could also play rook
f2 to guard the pawn this way but this
is even worse we're going to play rook
b8 and now we're just going to go after
the white king this rook is coming to g4
and you're not going to be able to
defend all of this for example knight to
f3 attacks the rook rook g4 now rook e2
to stop this rook the b1 check rook d1
and we just trade rook captures knight
captures now we're gonna play bishop to
e3 threat and checkmate and it's very
very ugly the knight will have to remain
here to defend against checkmate we're
gonna play bishop to b6 now everything
is defended we have a nice pass pawn
here and the position is completely
winning uh but okay it's move 37 we
still need to make three more moves to
reach time control uh and uh decided to
go for rook h captures on f4 we have
rook captures in the now bishop captures
on f4 knights the e4 by fabi uh and now
rook to a8
is ready to start pushing his past pawn
rook to c4 and now bishop to e5 here if
you just start pushing then you blunder
knight f3 double attack on the a4 pawn
and also the bishop is hanging so it is
a has to move the bishop first bishop to
e5 and now
uh rook to a4 fobby blocking the past
pawn king the g8 and the now king to g2
so from a completely drawn position favi
basically went into a position where he
has to fight for a draw voluntarily just
uh for for for a chance at uh maybe
winning the game so king to f7 we have
knight to d2 and the bishop to c3 now
attacking the knight knight e4 attacks
the bishop bishop to b4 controls the
knight also adds more uh protection to
this a5 pawn king f3 we have kinked the
e6 and now pawn to c3 uh chasing the
bishop back bishop to e7 again we
control the uh the knight very nicely
you all know that the bishop and knight
separated by two squares cancel each
other out usually uh so king to e3 and
now pawn to c6 we have h3 uh bishop to
d8 and now knight the c5 with check we
have king to f5 and not knight to b3 so
not much happening here uh basically uh
is trying to gain activity with his king
trying uh well you can't really push the
the rook away from the a4 square because
it's a light square
and you have a dark square bishop so you
can't
move it by four so you have to try
something else you have to create more
weaknesses but you are up a pawn and you
have a very active king so it should be
possible
but definitely not easy bishop to b6
with chuck king to f3 and now king to e5
uh and here fabi plays pawn to h4 uh we
have king to d5 pawn to h5 and now pawn
to c5 we have knight back to d2 uh
bishop to c7 and now king to e2 we have
rook to h8 going after the h5 pawn now
comes rook to g4 going after the g7 pawn
here we have a trade rook captures rook
captures and king the c6 now defending
the bishop and now alareza is up upon
but the position has already uh
completely uh simplified and you will
not be winning this anytime soon
we have king to d3 uh bishop to e5 and
now rook to f7 and here we have this a4
move and this is where things get very
very interesting this is move 59 one
more move needs to be made in order to
reach second time control which awards
you additional time you gain an
additional 15 minutes on the clock but
also you start getting increment because
there is no increment before hitting
move 60. so one more move needs to be
made
and fabi needs to make it a very precise
move something like knight to f3 or
knight to b1 or something like that but
definitely not the move uh fabi played
fabi played knight to e4
and this is now a mistake that will cost
him the game now but only if alireza
spots why this is so so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only winning move for alireza while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations uh on sporting that
this is uh yes uh one of those puzzles
where the winning move starts with a
check and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is rook to h3 with
check and now uh here comes the horror
uh the point is if king to c4 which is
kind of the the square that you want to
be because you have you you know that
your opponent has a dark square bishop
the knight guards the c3 pawn uh there's
no way to kick the king away from this
square i mean you know you're not losing
this the problem is uh there's a rook h4
what do you do here the only way to
defend the knight here is to play king
to d3 and now comes this very nasty c4
check you cannot capture because you
lose the knight with check and after
king to e3 the past pawn starts marching
forward and look at this rook to a7 okay
we put a rook behind the pass pawn rook
h3 check and now you have to defend the
pawn obviously as it's attacked twice so
king to d2 only move and now king to d5
we kick away the knight from the defense
of the c3 pawn knight the g5 attacks the
rook rook the h2 check king to e3 you
have to move it somewhere doesn't really
matter we're winning the pawn on the
next move so king e3 uh bishop captures
and now the problem is you can never
capture on a3 uh because if you capture
then uh bishop to d to check will pick
up the knight and without this capture
there is no hope of fighting for a draw
black is just up two pawns and of course
the position is completely winning so
after this rook to h3 check favi says
all right i'm not going to c4 i'm going
to play king to d2 but it doesn't matter
where the king goes the position is
winning regardless uh king to d5 just
kicks away the knight uh for away from
the defense of the c3 pawn knights the
f2 attacking the rook and now just rook
captures in c3 and now fabi's just down
two points and of course the position is
completely winning rook to f5 fabi tries
one more cheapo before he uh gives up
the game uh and here we have rook to g3
uh because of course if you start
pushing the pawn then just rook captures
with check and that's it king captures
king captures here and uh now you're not
winning now it's a draw but alareza
played rook to g3 and he was in this
position uh on move 63 that fabiano
caruana resigned the game and uh he
definitely had a terrible terrible
second half of the tournament losing
four games and drawing three i believe
that's uh i mean for uh for a player of
uh fabi's caliber that's unimaginable uh
and here you resign because you're just
down two pawns so let's say knights to
d3 it seems like you could win some
material here uh but just real captures
with chuck and there's no defense king
captures a3 you cannot stop the past
pawn because the bishop covers the a1
square and even if you go after it with
the rook we can just play a2 and
whatever you play a1 queen rook captures
bishop captures and there's still the
past c pawn so of course the position
will be winning so fabi saw this after
rook the g3 he resigned and uh well not
not a great second half of the
tournament for him but at least alireza
finishes the tournament on a high note
and as we've already discussed the
standings this means that alireza
finishes ahead of a young sister of duda
and rihard rapport of course you've seen
this already we've covered it in the
previous video but in case you haven't
yanni pomnishi is the winner of the
feeder candidates tournament and he
should be challenging magnus carlsen for
the title now uh also uh
uh
i forgot to mention the first move for
this game was made by the legend himself
former world champion vishwanathan anand
so there you have it let's just enjoy
that for uh for a brief a moment uh very
very nice photo uh and uh also uh here
are the uh as i mentioned the the
ranking these are the top 20 classical
players in the world so magnus still
untouchable with 2864 going for that
2900 rating
uh ding also started as a 2800 player
this candidates tournament finishes by
winning two points so 2808 that's
incredibly impressive and you can see
just how how strong ding is because you
you don't just start a tournament with a
2800 rating and finish a tournament with
a 2800 rating you've seen what happened
to alireza in the previous tournament
then janiponishi who almost finished the
tournament as a 2800 player he won 26.4
rating points and uh finished the
tournament as a 2792 player so really
really incredible alireza lost almost 15
points uh caruana
also lost 7.6 points nakamura won 7.8
points so now he goes up uh three places
he's currently number eight in the world
uh we have uh rihard rapport loses uh 13
points so he drops six places at a job
of wins nine points he goes up three
places and duda loses ten points drops
three places and that is the uh eight
those were the eight players that uh
have uh uh participated in this
candidates tournament so like i said
we've discussed pretty much everything
all the possibilities what happens the
next few challenges who uh in the
previous video so if you still haven't
seen it do check it out uh it will be
one of the you know one of the videos
uh so yeah that's the game definitely
the last game we'll be showing from the
feeder candidates tournament hope you
guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank gregory thomas jim tran surya
manikandan uh michael colbert and
richard sanderson for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day